you can easily judge the character of a
man
by how he treats those who can do
nothing for him
many people take no care of their money
till they come nearly to the end of it
and others do just the same with their
time
nothing is worth more than this day
of all the thieves idiots are the most
harmful
they steal from us our time
and mood
if you treat an individual as he is
he will remain how he is
but if you treat him as if he were what
he ought to be
and could be
he will become what he ought to be
what you get by achieving your goals is
not as important
as what you become by achieving your
goals
remember to live
life is too short to drink bad wine
what is not started today is never
finished tomorrow
doubt can only be removed by action
those who stopped loving and making
mistakes have buried themselves alive
no one would talk much in society if
they knew how often they misunderstood
others
the most ridiculous desire is the desire
to please everybody
too many parents make life hard for
their children by trying
too zealously
to make it easy for them
[Music]
what is uttered from the heart alone
will win the heart of others to your own
whoever wishes to keep a secret must
hide in the fact that he possesses one
everybody wants to be somebody
but nobody wants to grow
who is the happiest of men
he who values the merits of others and
in their pleasure takes joy
even as though
twere his own
oblivion is full of people who allow the
opinions of others
to overrule their belief in themselves
inspiration is not a herring
which can be pickled for many years
we all of us live upon the past
and through the past we are destroyed
he is happiest be he king or peasant
who finds peace
in his home
there is no past we can bring back by
longing for it
there is only an eternal now
that builds and creates out of the past
something new and better
for a man to achieve all that is
demanded of him
he must regard himself as greater than
he is
he who moves not forward
goes backwards
to be pleased with one's limits
is a wretched state
love is an ideal thing
marriage is a real thing
one always has time enough
if one will apply it well
the best government is that which
teaches us to govern ourselves
we know accurately only when we know
little
with knowledge doubt increases
[Music]
our friends show us
what we can do
our enemies teach us
what we must do
destiny grants us our wishes
but
in its own way
in order to give us something beyond our
wishes
[Music]
the intelligent man finds almost
everything ridiculous
the sensible man hardly anything
do not give in too much to feelings
a overly sensitive heart is an unhappy
possession on this shaky earth
go to foreign countries
and you will get to know the good things
one possesses at home
character is formed in the stormy
billows of the world
knowing is not enough
we must apply
willing is not enough
we must do
the way you see people is the way you
treat them
and the way you treat them
is what they become
as soon as you trust yourself
you will know how to live
the greatest thing in this world is not
so much where we stand
as in what direction we are moving
kindness is the golden chain by which
society is bound together
everything is hard before it is easy
[Music]
there is nothing in the world more
shameful
than establishing oneself on lies and
fables
nothing shows a man's character more
than what he laughs at
the greatest evil that can befall man is
that he should come to think ill of
himself
[Music]
i can tell you honest friend
what to believe
believe life it teaches better that book
or orator
which quote did you like the most
share your opinion in the comments
don't miss out on a chance to see the
next video subscribe
[Music]
you